[Musique]
c'est une information étonnante rébellie
hier soir par Le Canard Enchaîné un
homme a réussi à s'introduire dans le
palais présidentiel de l'Élysée dans les
deux s'introduire dans le palais
présidentiel un phénomène rarissime mais
pas inédit des tentatives d'intrusion
souvent stoppés net grâce à des gardes
ultra entraînées qui font de l'Élysée
une véritable forteresse
mais le 28 septembre dernier un homme a
bien failli s'approcher au plus près
d'Emmanuel Macron l'individu a réussi à
s'introduire dans le palais à quelques
mètres du bureau du président grâce à
des travaux en cours et aux flux
importants d'ouvriers va profiter va
bénéficier de ce flux pour s'introduire
jusqu'au marche du Pérou tandis que le
dispositif de sécurité a depuis été
renforcé l'intrus a été arrêté et risqué
aujourd'hui de lourdes sanctions alors
un homme s'introduit clandestinement à
l'Élysée le président est-il en danger
incroyable cette histoire vraiment
rester avec nous parce que elle est
folle Bruno Pommard mère de belles floue
c'est juste à côté d'Afflelou
expositions
voilà comment ça s'est passé si vous
voulez alors cette histoire il a dit
quoi au policiers comment ça se fait
qu'il a il a pu rentrer comme ça c'est
ce que je demande les gens quand on
arrive dans l'Élysée déjà je vous
explique quand vous arrivez dans l'idée
vous pouvez pas rester sur le trottoir
exactement
par Marini il y a 2 entrées alors que la
réplique officielle il y a l'entrée
Marini ou rentre tous les collaborateurs
parce qu'il a pris de 800 personnes qui
rentrent jour et nuit je dirais à
l'Élysée donc il y a une entrée qui
permet aux collaborateurs ou à
l'entreprise la fameuse entreprise qui
est venue réparer les les cuisines qui
venaient préparer des trucs il a réussi
à se faufiler à travers le filtre qui
est assuré par les gendarmes bon euh
mais il y a un défaut de sécurité sur
les côtés du palais parce que on peut
rentrer très facilement on allait
déjeuner au Metz qui était l'endroit où
on déjeuner c'était la cantine quoi de
la rue de l'Elysée et on repassait sans
être contrôlé il y avait pas de système
de contrôle les portes passées il y
avait plusieurs collaborateurs qui
rentraient vous pouviez vous mettre au
milieu des collaborateurs si vous êtes
collaborateur oui mais on rentre pas
comme ça les il faut
il faut savoir que il y a plusieurs
filtres vous avez vu comment il fait
l'Elysée vous avez la venue Marini la
venue
la rue de l'Elysée et l'avenue Gabriel
tout ça c'est sécurisé par la DOPC c'est
à dire la direction de la pupille c'est
la police
gendarmerie
les intérieurs c'est-à-dire tout la rue
l'entrée rue de Marigny l'entrée rue de
Élysée et l'entrée officielle est
assurée par les gendarmes républicaine
qui est en charge filtre on montre
évidemment une pièce d'identité etc il y
a il y a quand même filtre et différence
vous avez dit tout à l'heure il est
monté les escaliers et moi j'ai George
Salinas qui est le patron du GSPR il est
arrivé juste ici devant voilà
les médias les médias étaient pas dans
le bureau du président
parce que là quand vous entrez dans le
sein des saints ici vous avez la garde
républicaine ne sont pas que des pots de
fleurs les gars c'est les gars c'est
capable de faire la sécurité il y a les
huissiers qui sont là qui assurent une
sécurité permanente au cas où il paye
quand même ses amis
au cas où président le loyer
300 à assurer la sécurité du président
il faut savoir entre la BSPP c'est ça
qui est fait peur
jusqu'au bureau du président Marie le
problème c'est que
regardez rappelez-vous juste la
tentative de l'assassinat sur le
président Reagan sécurité maximum
secrétaire service plus personne ne peut
rien il a fallu ça a été la même chose
donc on peut tout faire
la gifle au président de la République
là il y a quelqu'un qui rentre dans le
palais c'est quand même préoccupant si
vous voulez c'est on est quand même la
6e ou 7e essence du monde qu'on puisse
rentrer comme ça et se présenter au
président de la République pour lui
donner son CV il était à quelques mètres
le président tenait un conseil avec des
collaborateurs
non je dis monsieur tiens des
informations de la bouche du cheval moi
c'est des dépêche et cetera c'est pas
oui c'est ça oui mais
c'est qui
c'est pas tout de lire les dépêches il
faut juste avoir les bonnes informations
en l'occurrence le patron j'espère il
s'appelle monsieur Salina je l'ai eu une
demi-heure avant il faut pas dire
n'importe quoi c'est important
je dis pas n'importe quoi mais la
sécurité sociale allez lisez le sécurité
le président est hyper sécurisé là c'est
un mix de genre du GIGN et du SLP le
service de la protection malgré tout
Bruno
encore une fois s'il y a des filtres on
vous la montrer les filtres extérieurs
on l'a dit avec la dû au PC à
l'intérieur les gendarmes et encore à
l'intérieur vous avez le GSM parce que
et pour arriver dans le bureau du
président même s'il monte les escaliers
tout est verrouillé toutes les
sécurisément
ce que le jeune homme a dit aux
policiers et il a été très convaincant
Cyril il a dit je suis rentré sans
contrôle sans autorisation l'alouette
était ouverte j'ai profité de me glisser
derrière un gendarme et je suis arrivé
là et en fait il avait postulé
effectivement pour un job et il a dit
chez au chômage gagne 700 euros par mois
je voulais demander un travail président
il a profité de l'entrée de plusieurs
personnes voilà
il est rentré avec un groupe de
personnes oui nuance comme ça
il y a une erreur il a tellement été
convaincant auprès des policiers du 16e
arrondissement il n'avait pas de une
présentait pas de danger pas lâcher et
que l'affaire a été classée 100 %
alors que normalement il risque un an de
prison un bâtiment militaire
il a été à garde à vue au commissariat
du 16e il a été interrogé évidemment en
regardant ce qu'il a fait nous on s'en
fout euh tu poses des questions
il y a une procédure évidemment il y a
un cours c'est normal mais encore une
fois la sécurité c'est pas quelque chose
non mais est-ce que tu es le Président
il est énervé après ça fait un truc
comme ça il avait été appelé les
services vont se remettre en question
aussi évidemment les patrons de la
sécurité comment il est rentré c'est ça
le truc qu'il a dit quoi mais il est
rentré
dans un groupe sur une rue qui est
perpendiculaire à la rue du Faubourg
Saint-Honoré qui est l'avenue marine tu
passes sur le trottoir tu passes de
juste devant l'entrée et donc
pardon ils ont pas calculés étonnant
c'est qu'il est pas calculé aux abords
du Palais parce qu'il faut bien savoir
pour ceux qui sont pas parisien que
autour du palais de l'Élysée il y a des
barrières un peu partout qui a des
patrouilles je me rappelle quand j'y
travaillais j'avais mon badge et si je
présente aussi mon badge à tous les
endroits oui c'est là qu'on s'est connu
d'ailleurs Cyril si j'avais pas mon
badge j'allais lisais à l'époque je
pouvais pas passer une fois je l'ai
oublié il s'est un collaborateur qui
était à l'intérieur du palais d'Elysée
qui est venu me chercher on a passé
définitive comme en bois j'ai du mal
sorti des finances je la seule
différence c'est que la venue Marini on
peut s'y balader sans problème
à être 21h09 on est en direct 21h10 un
mec il est quand même rentré dans
l'Élysée c'est quand même fou
moi j'ai peur
des tartines on est sur un contexte
dangereux c'est pas le président le
président
le président
le patron du hrpcg de Lille
c'est un policier d'expérience
il y a évidemment une cellule de crise
évidemment on en discute c'est pas par
hasard c'est arrivé évidemment mais
encore une fois la sécurité c'est pas
une semence
il a fait sortir l'info toujours parce
que c'est sorti bien tard après que ce
soit déroulé mais le signal il est quand
même hyper dangereux si vous on est
quand même dans un contexte de
terrorisme on est dans le contexte avec
l'islam politique et un point important
avec des militants politiques et là on
s'aperçoit quelqu'un qui n'est pas non
plus un j.i ou un combattant d'élite
arrive à rentrer au sein du Palais
d'Elise et comme ça en se fondant au
milieu des ouvriers à quelques mètres du
bureau de le président de la République
alors moi je veux bien qu'on dise qu'il
y a pas de problème et que la sécurité
marche très bien mais permettez-moi
d'avoir un doute légitime sur ce qu'il y
a ça
de vous lire il y a plusieurs c'est pour
ça qu'il y a plusieurs filtres
d'ailleurs bien sûr parce que évidemment
il est passé en premier filtre le
deuxième filtre il est il a réussi à y
passer
partout puisqu'il était interpellé
c'était un mec qui voulait du travail
c'est les mecs imagine le mec qu'il
avait une bombe un truc et il se fait
sauter sur la cour de la cour de l'idée
c'est ça non c'est certain que tu
voulais penser mais oui c'est ça en fait
parce que lui ça va mais imaginez si je
sais pas une ceinture une bombe et tout
ça en fait est-ce qu'il y a un détecteur
de bande de métaux au départ dès le
premier dès la première rentrée pas dans
les emplois dans les petites entrées
dans la grande entrée sur Marigny et sur
même quand tu livres mais le problème
parce que il rentrait sans rien le gars
et si tu rentres sans rien ça sonne pas
de papier il y a pas de souci
le déclic pour voilà donc il y a pas de
raison de s'inquiéter
c'est déjà très sérieux qui bossent rien
il s'agit pas de douter du sérieux des
gens qui entourent le président de la
République j'espère qui est quand même
une unité d'élite c'est parce que j'ai
dit tout ce que je dis c'est qu'on a le
droit en tant que citoyen de se poser la
question la sécurité du président quand
on a vu qu'en plus il y a quelques mois
maintenant année il s'est fait gifler
aussi
on déplacement sécurité
des gens ça c'est encore un autre sujet
bien sûr mais c'est quand même toujours
le sujet de la protection rapprochée du
Président de la République en tout cas
on a eu plus d'infos sur cette affaire